YOU WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
CIVIL WAR NOW IN PROGRESS IN
JUST A MOMENT.
FIRST TONIGHT, THERE ARE
SERIOUS LONG-TERM PROBLEMS
FACING AMERICA AS WE HAVE
TOLD YOU ABOUT FOR YEARS ON
THIS SHOW.
THANKS FOR OUTSOURCING, THIS
COUNTRY NO LONGER HAS THE
SAME RESERVE THE STABLE
MIDDLE CLASS MANUFACTURING
JOBS WE DID EVEN 30 YEARS
AGO.
>> IN COASTAL CITIES,
HOUSING HAS BECOMES A ASTRO
NO, MA’AM MICLY EXPENSIVE.
PRICES ARE RISING FAR
QUICKER THAN WAGE GROWTH AND
MOST TRAGICALLY OPIOID
EPIDEMIC KILLS TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS EVERY
YEAR.
ONE OF THE REASONS FENTANYL
IS SMUGGLED IN FROM ABROAD.
THESE MIGHT SEEM LIKE
UNRELATED PROBLEMS, BUT THEY
ARE NOT.
A SINGLE THEME UNITES THEM.
A SYSTEMATIC DECISION BY
MANY OF OUR COUNTRY’S MOST
POWERFUL LEADERS TO SELL OUT
AMERICA TO CHINA.
THOSE JOBS THAT WERE
OUTSOURCED THEY WENT TO
CHINA.
THOSE RISING HOME PRICES ALL
CASH CHINESE BUYERS ARE A
MAJOR TRIBUTER TO THAT
ALMOST NEVER SAID OUT LOUD.
FENTANYL MADE IN CHINA WITH
THE KNOWLEDGE AND TACET
APPROVAL OF THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
CHINA IS NO LONGER SIMPLE AN
ECONOMIC RIVAL OF THE UNITED
STATES.
IT’S BECOMING A DANGEROUS
ENEMY.
INSTEAD OF PROTECTING US
FROM THIS THREAT AN
EXISTENTIAL ONE OUR
LEADERSHIP CLASS
COLLABORATES WITH THE OTHER
SIDE.
WHY DO THEY DO THAT?
SIMPLE, THEY ARE GETTING
RICH FROM IT.
THIS ONLY BECAME CLEAR TO
MANY PEOPLE A FEW MONTHS AGO
WHEN THE MOST AMERICAN OF
ALL SPORTS, PROFESSIONAL
BASKETBALL A GAME LITERALLY
INVENTED IN A GYM IN
SPRINGFIELD, MASSACHUSETTS
RIPPED OFF THE MASK AND
SHOWED THE WORLD WHO REALLY
CONTROLS THE LEAGUE.
NBA GENERAL MANAGER DARRYL
MOREY YOU WILL REMEMBER
WROTE A TWEET SUPPORTING
PRO-DEMOCRACY PROTESTERS IN
HONG KONG.
IN BASH LASH NBA AND MOREY
APOLOGIZED FOR CRITICIZING
THE REGIME AND LEBRON JAMES
WEIGHED IN ACTUALLY FREEDOM
OF SPEECH IN AMERICA IS
VASTLY OVERRATED.
>> SO MANY PEOPLE COULD HAVE
BEEN HARMED, NOT ONLY
FINANCIALLY BUT PHYSICALLY,
EMOTIONALLY, SPIRITUALLY.
SO, JUST BE CAREFUL WHAT WE
TWEET AND WE SAY AND WHAT WE
DO, EVEN THOUGH, YES, WE DO
HAVE FREEDOM OF SPEECH BUT
THERE CAN BE A LOT OF
NEGATIVE THAT COMES WITH
THAT, TOO.
>> Tucker: UM-HUH.
JUST BE CAREFUL WITH WHAT
YOU TWEET OR SAY BECAUSE THE
CHINESE ARE WATCHING AND
THEY PAY THE BILLS.
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS COACH
STEVE KERR MEANWHILE
EXPLAINED THERE IS REALLY NO
MORAL DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
AMERICA AND COMMUNIST CHINA.
>> IT DOES NOT COME UP IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE ASKING ME
ABOUT IT.
PEOPLE DISCUSSING IT.
NO.
NOR HAS OUR RECORD OF HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES EITHER.
PEOPLE IN CHINA DIDN’T ASK
ME ABOUT, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
OWNING AR-15s AND MOWING
EACH OTHER DOWN IN A MALL.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
SO AMERICA HAS SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS, CHINA IS ON ITS
THIRD OR FOURTH GENOCIDE
SINCE WORLD WAR II.
YOU KNOW TOMATO, TOMATO.
SIX DOZEN ONE, WHATEVER.
YEAH.
SAYING SOMETHING LIKE THAT
OUT LOUD SHOULD BE SHOCKING
BUT IT’S NOT REALLY.
IT’S A TASTE OF JUST HOW
COMPLETELY THE PEOPLE IN
CHARGE IDENTIFY WITH CHINA
OVER THIS COUNTRY.
IN SOME CASES THEY HAVE
LITERALLY JOINED CHINA’S
PAYROLL.
FORMER ILLINOIS SENATOR MARK
KIRK IS A REGISTERED FOREIGN
AGENT WHO LOBBIES FOR THE
CHINA U.S. TRADE FOUNDATION
CHINA ORGANIZATION WITH TIES
TO A FORMER COMMUNIST PARTY.
THAT’S A SENATOR.
SENATOR JOE LIEBERMAN WORKED
FOR ZFRMT TE.
SO DANGEROUS TO AMERICAN
INTEREST THAT LAST AUGUST
THE PRESIDENT SIGNED A BILL
BANNING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FROM USING THAT
COMPANY’S EQUIPMENT.
BECAUSE IT’S TOO
THREATENING.
HE IS LOBBYING FOR THEM.
FORMER CONGRESSMAN RICH
VOUCH EVERYWHERE HAS LOBBIED
FOR A WHOLE LIST OF CHINESE
COMPANIES, HICK VISION, WOW; LAS
NIGHT ON THIS PROGRAM WE
TELLING YOU ABOUT A MAN
CALLED U MANNING.
MASSIVE STATE RUN PENSION
FUND CALLED CALIPERS.
MANNING BORN IN CHINA
PREVIOUSLY RAN CHINA’S
3-MILLION-DOLLAR PORTFOLIO
OF FOREIGN INVESTMENTS.
CULL PERS HAS LONG ENGAGED
IN SHAREHOLDER ADVANCEMENTS
IN THIS COUNTRY LIKE GUN
CONTROL AND BEEN VERY
AGGRESSIVE ABOUT IT.
NOW THE FUND ALSO SUPPORTS
CHINA’S EFFORTS TO ECLIPSE
AMERICA.
CALIPERS INVEST IN COMPANIES
THAT INVEST IN CHINESE
MILITARY HICK VISION THAT
MAKES SURVEILLANCE EQUIPMENT
THAT MONITOR UIGHURS
ACTIVELY ABETTING FASCISM.
NOTHING HARMFUL ABOUT THESE
INVESTMENTS AS HE ONCE
QUOTED OF COURSE IT EMPOWERS
THE CHINESE REGIME TO HAVE
THE MONEY FLOWING IN.
OF COURSE THEY DO.
THOUSAND TALENTS INITIATIVE
CHINESE PROGRAM DESIGNED TO
ENCOURAGE FORMER
BUSINESSMEN, SCIENTISTS AND
OTHER EXPERTS TO WORK ON
CHINA’S BEHALF, OFTEN
SECRETLY.
THE EXPLICIT GOAL IS TO
OBTAIN WESTERN TECHNOLOGY
AND RESEARCH FOR CHINA’S OWN
USE SO THEY CAN SURPASS US,
WHICH THEY ARE.
LAST MONTH HARVARD CHEMISTRY
PROFESSOR CHARLES LIEBER THE
HEAD OF THE DEPARTMENT WAS
ARRESTED FOR HIDING HIS WORK
ON BEHALF 6 CHINA.
IN EFFECT LIEBER WAS WORKING
AS A SPY BUT HIS CASE ISN’T
SPECIAL.
THE ENTIRE SLEAZY ACADEMIC
WORLD AND IT’S ONE OF THE
SLEAZIEST IS ADDICTED TO
CHINESE MONEY.
HARVARD AND YALE STAND
ACCUSED OF HIDING HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF CHINESE
PAYMENTS.
NEEDLESS TO SAY CHINA IS ONE
OF THE TOP CONTRIBUTORS.
RECENTLY THE TEXAS A&M
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM TRIED TO
GAUGE HOW MUCH OF ITS FALK
KUEHL AT THIS WAS GETTING
CHINESE MONEY.
MORE THAN 100 HAD BEEN
RECRUITED IT TURNS OUT.
ONLY FIVE REPORTED THEIR
WORK FOR HOSTILE FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT.
HOW MANY INDICTED YEAH YOU
GUESSED IT ZERO.
CHINESE OFFICIALS AREN’T
PAYING ACADEMICS BECAUSE
THEY LOVE SCHOLARSHIP.
NO, AMERICA’S UNIVERSITIES
ARE KEY CENTERS OF
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH AND
TECHNICAL INNOVATION.
CHINA WOULD LIKE TO STEAL
THAT INFORMATION.
AND THEY ARE.
AS OF TONIGHT, THE FBI IS
INVESTIGATING MORE THAN
1,000 CASES IN WHICH THEY
BELIEVE CHINA HAS STOLEN
RESEARCH FROM AMERICAN
FIRMS.
IF ANYTHING, OUR TOP
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
ARE ENCOURAGING THIS TO
HAPPEN.
AND YOU CAN SEE IT BY THE
WAY THEY RECRUIT.
CHINESE GRAD STUDENTS FILL
OUR RESEARCH LABS.
THIS MAKES COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS MUCH RICHER
BUT ALSO ALLOWS THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT EASY ACCESS TO
CRITICAL INFORMATION.
SOME OF IT THAT DIRECTLY
BEARS ON OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
AMERICAN ACADEMICS HAVE MADE
IT CLEAR WHOSE SIDE THEY ARE
ON.
LAST NOVEMBER OFFICIALS AT
UNIVERSITY OF MISSOURI
KANSAS CITY REMOVED ARTISTIC
DISPLAY SUPPORTING
PROTESTERS IN HONG KONG
BECAUSE CHINESE STUDENTS
COMPLAINED.
ACCORDING TO THE NEW REMUST
BE BIBLICAL COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY GLOBAL CENTER IN
BEIJING CANCELLED TALKS
BECAUSE THEY MIGHT UPSET
CHINESE OFFICIALS.
THEY ARE SQUELCHING FREE
SPEECH AT THE DIRECTION OF
COMMUNIST CHINA.
THAT’S COMMON IN THE
BUSINESS WORLD.
DISNEY CHANGED ITS TIBETAN
CHARACTER IN ONE OF ITS
MOVIES INTO EUROPEAN WOMAN
BECAUSE ACKNOWLEDGING
TIBET’S EXISTENCE WOULD
ANGER THEIR MASTERS IN
CHINA.
THEY SHOULD BE ASHAMED.
GAP APOLOGIZED FOR SELLING A
T-SHIRT IN CANADA THAT
DIDN’T FEATURE TIJUANA AS
SUPPORT OF CHINA.
BY THE WAY IT’S NOT PART OF
CHINA.
BUT CHINA DEMANDED THAT GAP
PRETEND IT IS AND THEY
COMPLIED.
WE COULD GO ON.
THERE ARE ENDLESS EXAMPLES
OF THIS KIND OF THING.
IT’S HAPPENING ALL AROUND
US.
SO HOW ABOUT MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG?
HE IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
MAYBE MORE THAN ANY ONE IN
AMERICA, BLOOMBERG
REPRESENTS THE BELIEFS AND
VALUES OF OUR CURRENT
ARISTOCRACY WHICH IS BY FAR
THE WORST IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THE STUPIDEST, THE MOST
GREEDY.
NOT SURPRISINGLY, BLOOMBERG
HAS BOTH KOWTOWED TO THE
CHINESE AND GOTTEN RICH FROM
THE CHINESE.
HE IS NOT EMBARRASSED BY IT
IN 2014 BLOOMBERG EXPLAINED
THAT ACTUALLY CHINA’S
UNELECTED LEADER ISN’T
REALLY A DICTATOR.
>> THE COMMUNIST PARTY WANTS
TO STAY IN POWER IN CHINA.
AND THEY LISTEN TO THE
PUBLIC.
WHEN THE PUBLIC SAYS I CAN’T
BREATHE THE AIR, XI JINPING
IS NOT A DICTATOR.
HE HAS TO SATISFY HIS
CONSTITUENTS OR HE IS NOT
GOING TO SURVIVE.
>> HE IS NOT A DICTATOR?
>> NO, HE HAS A CONSTITUENCY
TO ANSWER TO.
>> Tucker: SO THE CHINESE
DICTATOR IS NOT A DICTATOR.
MAKES YOU WONDER HOW MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG WOULD GOVERN AS
PRESIDENT OR MAYBE IT
EXPLAINS HOW HE WOULD GOVERN
AS PRESIDENT.
BLOOMBERG’S PERSONAL
ADMIRATION FOR THE
BLOOD-THIRSTY FOSSIL IN
CHARGE OF THE WORLD’S
LARGEST COMMUNIST COUNTRY.
ISN’T THE ONLY REASON HE
LIKES CHINA.
BIG MONEY AT STAKE.
ALWAYS WHAT IT IS ABOUT.
BLOOMBERG’S COMPANY HAS
ENORMOUS INVESTMENTS IN THE
COUNTRY HOW BLOOMBERG NEWS
REPORTS ON CHINA.
BLOOMBERG NEWS WAS ACCUSED
OF KILLING STORIES THAT
WOULD HAVE REVEALED
CORRUPTION BY FAMILY MEMBERS
OF THE CHINESE DICTATOR AND,
YES, HE IS A DICTATOR.
BEN RICHARDSON BLOOMBERG’S
ASIA EDITOR HAD BEEN TOLD
DIRECTLY BY LEADERS AT HIS
COMPANY THAT COVERING THE
CHINESE POLITICS BUREAU IS
OFF LIMITS.
THAT’S LIKE TELLING A
WASHINGTON BUREAU CHIEF YOU
CAN’T COVER CONGRESS BECAUSE
YOU MIGHT INSULT THEM.
THAT’S MICHAEL BLOOMBERG’S
POSITION.
JUST TODAY FINCHER WROTE IN
THE INTERCEPT HOW
BLOOMBERG’S LAWYERS
THREATENED TO DESTROY HER
LIFE IF SHE WOULDN’T SIGN A
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENT
ABOUT THE COMPANY’S
CENSORSHIP PRACTICES.
BUT DON’T TAKE THEIR WORD
FOR IT.
A FEW YEARS AGO BLOOMBERG
OPENLY ADMITTED THAT HE LET
CHINA SENSOR HIS COMPANY’S
NEWS.
HE ACTUALLY SAID THAT ON
TELEVISION.
HERE IT IS.
>> OVER THE PAST YEAR THERE
HAS BEEN QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
JOURNALISM GOING ON IN CHINA
AND WHETHER THE COMPANY IN
ITS EFFORT TO GROW HAS
MUZZLED.
>> IN CHINA, THEY HAVE RULES
ABOUT WHAT CAN YOU PLUSH.
WE FOLLOWPUBLISH.
WE FOLLOW THOSE RULES.
IF YOU DON’T FOLLOW THE
RULES, YOU AREN’T IN THE
COUNTRY.
WE WRITE THE STORIES THAT
ARE INTERESTING AND
DISTRIBUTE THEM WHERE THEY
ARE ALLOWED TO BE
DISTRIBUTED.
>> Tucker: WHERE THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO BE DISTRIBUTED.
THE SCARIEST PART IS THAT AS
CHINA HAS GROWN MORE
POWERFUL, AMERICA HAS GROWN
MORE DEPENDENT ON IT.
OUTSOURCING OUR
MANUFACTURING POWER BROUGHT
AMERICAN COMPANIES BIG
SHORT-TERM PROFITS.
HEAD TO FLORIDA AND SEE THE
HOUSES THEY BROUGHT BOUGHT WITH
PROFITS.
MADE US DANGEROUSLY
DEPENDENT ON.
CONSIDER MEDICAL SUPPLIES.
CHINA IS NOW A TOP PRODUCER
OF A ANTIBIOTICS SURGICAL
TOOLS, FACE MASKS AND MANY
MORE ESSENTIAL PRODUCTS THAT
YOU NEED TO STAY ALIVE.
80% OF OUR ANTIBIOTICS RIGHT
NOW COME FROM CHINA.
HARD TO BELIEVE BUT TRUE.
THE CORONAVIRUS PANIC ALONE
WAS ENOUGH TO CAUSE
SHORTAGES OF SOME OF THESE
MATERIALS.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF AN EVEN
BIGGER CRISIS COMES ALONG AS
CONTINUE EVIDENT CONTINUABLY
WILL OR WHAT IF CHINA CUTS
OFF EXPORTS AS A SHOW OF
FORCE?
THAT COULD HAPPEN.
MAYBE THEY INVADE TIJUANA
AND THEN CUT OFF EXPORTS?
HOW WOULD RERESPOND?
WE WOULD BE HELPLESS.
THE SADDEST AND MOST
INFURIATING PART IS THAT
NONE OF THIS NEEDED TO
HAPPEN IN THE FIRST PLACE.
CHINA DIDN’T JUST ONE DAY
MAGICALLY OVERTAKE US.
OUR LEADERS MADE THAT
POSSIBLE THEY ABETTED IT.